le ministre de l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve l invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir monsieur le ministre soit et
merci d'être avec nous donc pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse représenter ce soir
par un cat et le prix jean en
association également avec dailymotion
et bien sûr perrine tarneaud de public
sénat sera avec nous à la fin de cette
édition
il est des moments difficiles dans la
vie d'un ministre de l'intérieur
particulièrement et douloureusement
lorsqu'un manifestant meurt lors d'un
moment de tension extrême avec les
forces de l'ordre on a tous en à
l'esprit la mort de malik oussékine en
1986 la compassion manifesté pour la
famille de rémy fraysse s'accompagne de
l'indispensable recherche de vérité à
laquelle vous avez décidé d'apporter
votre concours bien sûr mais vous
suspendez l'utilisation des grenades
offensives il s'agit donc d'une bavure
nous ne s'agit pas d'une bavure on
pouvait présenter les choses ainsi vous
évoquez tout à l'heure le cas de malik
oussékine les deux situations n'ont rien
à voir l'une avec l'autre on sait les
circonstances dans lesquelles malik
oussékine avaient été poursuivis frappé
et avaient trouvé la mort là nous sommes
dans un tout autre contexte
nous sommes dans un contexte où au terme
de procédures de droit respecté une
installation a été autorisée contestée
par un certain nombre de groupes et de
manifestants cette contasté de
contestation allait légitime dans la
république on peut toujours contester et
le rôle lui misé de l'intérieur et de
faire en sorte lorsqu'il ya des
contestations et des manifestations
qu'elles puissent se dérouler dans le
respect de la sécurité de
visiteurs du drame non le 10 mai fais ce
que je dis qu'il ya eu depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines des violences
répétées il ait eu 56 policiers et
gendarmes qui ont été blessés
il est hué 80 une procédure judiciaire
ouverte dont 39 pour des raisons qui
tenait à des violences commises à
l'encontre des forces de leur jeunesse
et c'est au cours des dernières semaines
alors que le dossier de sylvain ce n'est
pas un dossier géré par le ministère de
l'intérieur même pas par l'état français
puisque c'est un dossier dont la
maîtrise d'ouvragé est assurée par une
collectivité locale gal général du tarn
d'appeler au calme et à la
responsabilité et 10 en grande partie
des manifestants de sivens y compris du
week-end était pacifique et il y avait à
l'intérieur des manifestants plusieurs
centaines de personnes désireuses d'en
découdre
est-ce que c'est colonel rémy fraysse
d'après nos informations les
informations qui me sont communiquées
que ce garçon tu es d'un garçon
pacifique qui n'avait pas ce profil
mêlant quête établira les conditions
dans lesquelles les événements se sont
produits alors et moi tous les jours
dans ma responsabilité de mise de
l'intérieur depuis des semaines je suis
confronté à des violences je suis
confronté à des exactions ça a été
encore le cas à gaillac c'est quand
encore été le cas à nantes
ça a encore été le cas à albi avec des
forces de l'ordre qui essaient de faire
en sorte que des biens et des personnes
soient protégés est-ce que tu obtiens
exigé que la police port bou et donc du
ministre mais c'est un échec tu la
société parce qu'il ya de la violence de
la gendarmerie ont l'établira pourquoi
faut-il alors même qu'une enquête
judiciaire est en cours et n'a pas fait
connaître son verdict parce que le
progrès mais en moins privilégient la
thèse d'un décès donc due à une grenade
offensive lancée par les gendarmes bien
entendu que c'est l'hypothèse qui
privilégie mais son départ aux termes de
l' enquête il faut déterminer si cette
grenade a été lancée dans le respect des
principes qui révise le code de la
sécurité intérieure du doigt il peut
très bien y avoir eu ce drame dans un
contexte sans pour autant que de fautes
étaient est commise il faut quand même
dans
le climat de tension et de violence qui
existe non seulement en france mais dans
d'autres pays d'europe quand on a une
parole publique avoir une parole
responsable et moi je sais qu'il y a
tous les jours des policiers et des
gendarmes qui exposent leur vie pour
assurer la sécurité des français
il y a chaque année des policiers des
gendarmes et des pompiers qui perdent
leur vie pour assurer la sécurité des
français j'étais il ya de cela quelques
semaines aux obsèques de sandrine morte
à sedan l'heure qu'il est ses trois
enfants et à ce moment là je n'ai pas
entendu beaucoup de déclarations donc je
souhaite simplement apporter mon soutien
aux forces de l'ordre qui font un
travail difficile et il est normal que
le ministre de l'intérieur exige que
l'engagement des forces de l'ordre se
fasse dans le strict respect des règles
et du droit républicain c'est le cas du
travail fait par les forces de l'ordre
il peut y avoir des problèmes il
appartient à la justice de dire quelles
sont ces problèmes
par conséquent moi je souhaite que tous
ceux qui aujourd'hui accusent tous ceux
qui aujourd'hui s'indignent et
s'insurgent veuille bien attendre des
parce que j'imagine qu'ils sont soucieux
comme moi tu respect la furia de droit
que la vérité fassent leur chemin
ça n'est pas de les brûler la justice
faire ce travail n'est pas une bavure
des forces de l'ordre dit vouer bernard
cazeneuve manuel vals ambitieux et une
enquête et que je souhaiterais qu'on
laisse la justice faire cette enquête
j'ai pris un engagement parce que je
partage
au plus profond de moi-même précisément
parce que je suis ministre de
l'intérieur cette souffrance de la cie
disparition de ce jeune garçon comme
d'autres élus politiques j'ai des
enfants qui ont l'âge ce jeune garçon
qui est mort et par conséquent je suis
dans un sentiment de profonde tristesse
et même si chacun exprime les choses à
sa manière selon son tempérament et se
manifeste à l'égard de la famille
commune estime devoir le faire dans ma
responsabilité de mise à l'intérieur
précisément parce que j'ai cette
fonction j'ai ressenti cela comme une
blessure il a par conséquence je veux la
vérité sur cette affaire
pour cette raison-là cette vérité elle
est un devoir moral est un devoir d'état
on la doit à la famille et je me battrai
heure après heure pour que cette vérité
soit possible pour le front de gauche
une façon pour le gouvernement
aujourd'hui d'assumer sa responsabilité
serait que vous quittez vos fonctions
que répondez-vous au parti de jean luc
mélenchon il ya toujours des gens qui
chassent en meute qui demandent des
têtes avant même que la justice n'ait
fait son travail selon sont souvent
d'ailleurs les mêmes qui prétendent
porter la république en bandoulière
mais quand on est soucieux des règles de
la république
on attend que la justice fasse son
oeuvre on ne fait pas des déclarations
qui sont de nature à faire pression sur
elle on ne procède pas à des accusations
si l'on ne sait pas et on se renseigne
sur les conditions dans lesquelles les
faits se sont produits avant d'avoir des
propos définitifs et par ailleurs on ne
peut pas à la fois tous les jours par
des propos outranciers par des
invectives créer un climat et s'étonner
ensuite des conséquences du clan
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes fort de la
confiance ce que carac a réitéré
d'ailleurs le projet de jj sur toi fort
endroit mais je suis surtout fort de
l'exercice que le fait de ma conscience
parce que quand on est dans une
responsabilité comme la mienne on sait
les instructions que l'on donne on sait
la déontologie que l'on veut faire
prévaloir
on sait la sincérité que l'on met sur le
métier qu'on ne se laisse pas
impressionner par des acteurs qui ne
font que de la polémique
on est qu'ils ne font que de la petite
politique en ayant à passer peu le souci
des valeurs et des principes alors je
suis profondément républicain j'ai été
dans l'opposition pendant des années à
l'assemblée nationale j'ai eu comme vous
le savez a mené d enquête parlementaire
sur des drames qui avait conduit au
décès de
ressortissant français je pense à
karachi 14 moi jamais je n'ai mis en
accusation tel ou tel adversaire en
politique si j'estimais que les faits ne
le justifiait pas parce que il y a une
éthique de l'action publique
il y a une éthique de la responsabilité
alors j'espère moi je ne suis pas de
ceux qui chassent ensemble
alors d'accord avec vous autres semblait
viser là certains écologistes un homme
dans le classique notamment je ne pense
pas je ne vise personne est ce que vous
lisez ce qui met quand même nom en
partie responsables des violences
comprend que comme l'a dit françois
fillon
s'il me permettait de seconde je ne vise
personne en particulier parce que moi je
ne suis pas dans le désir de la
polémique la polémique je la subis
je subis des accusations j'ai entendu ce
matin que l'on disait que j'étais
responsable de la mort de ce jeune
garçon et et bien entendu vous imaginez
ce que cela peut signifier lorsque l'on
est un ministre de l'intérieur
profondément républicain est attaché un
certain nombre de valeurs que d'entendre
cela à l'emporte-pièce nous envier dans
les rangs de la gauche que l'on entend
cela à droite au centre
mais où noah à ces critiques moi ce que
je vous dis simplement ce soir c'est
qu'il n'y a qu'une chose qui m'apporte
un la vérité
2 la responsabilité et je ne serai pas
précisément parce que le sous ministre
de l'intérieur dans un contexte où il ya
des tensions où il ya des violences de
ceux qui font des phrases pour rajouter
de la tension à la tension golf et
attiser des flammes en s'étonnant après
qui le ferait ce que vous pensez que la
famille de rémy fraises va se sentir
renforcés dans sa plainte pour homicide
volontaire au vu des dernières
informations même si vous nous dites que
l' enquête n'a pas encore totalement
abouti et je vous ai dit que j'estime
qu'il n'ya qu'une chose que l'on doit la
famille de rémy frais c'est la vérité la
famille de rémy fraysse déposé plainte
elle attend que la vérité soit faite
parce qu'elle est dans une
incommensurable et insondable souffrance
dans un grand chagrin et célérité
on la doit et cette plainte permettra
aussi à l' enquête de se dérouler et
d'atteindre son but encore une question
semble-t-il le présent du département du
tarn
suspendre le projet c'est une
information en tous les cas de jean
vincent placé qui a eu et donc des
confidences vous considère effectivement
qu'on ne peut plus aujourd'hui
construire un barrage sur un cadavre
comme l'a dit noël mamère moi je ne
commente pas des confidences il y a eu à
gérer une décision mais je n'aurais pas
d'information sur ce sujet de ce que je
peux simplement dire c'est que dans le
respect des principes républicains il ya
le respect du droit si l'on veut
l'apaisement retrouver la paix dans le
respect du droit
ça doit être comme moi un sujet sur
lequel tous les républicains tombent
d'accord et dans cette affaire quoi
qu'on pense du projet on a le droit
d'exprimer ce que l'on pensait de
manifester contre ce projet si on n'y
est pas favorable
toutes les procédures de droits ont été
respectés
ensuite il appartient aux maîtres
d'ouvragé le départ et lire la suite qui
souhaitent donner à ce dossier alors on
va évoquer les collectivités
territoriales qui sont soucieuses de
leurs prérogatives mais aussi de leur
survie dans le cadre donc de la réforme
que manuel valls est venu défendre avec
vous devant les sénateurs le premier
ministre affirme qu'il veut tenir compte
des propositions du sénat mais justement
le sénat a dessiné une carte de 15 et
non pas treize régions
et là vous dites non d'emblée non il va
y avoir un débat au cours des prochaines
heures auxquelles elle a participé
puisque c'est moi qui porterait ce texte
devant le sénat le débat n'est pas la
renonciation de chacun à dire ce qu'ils
pensent bon nous connaissons la position
du sénat elle a été exprimée au travers
le les amendements adoptés par la
commission spéciale ces amendements
d'ailleurs concernant la carte apporte
de modification à celle qui avait été
adoptée à l'assemblée nationale et qui
n'était pas la carte du gouvernement
puisque les parlementaires députés
avaient eux-mêmes apporter les
modifications la disjonction de
midi-pyrénées et de languedoc-roussillon
et la disjonction de l'alsace de la
grande région test
le gouvernement n'est pas favorable à
ces amendements et il va donc par
conséquent l'exprimer et un débat s'est
bien entendu
d'autant plus riche que chacun exprime
sa position dans le respect de venir
aussi d'écouter le retenir mais notre
ambition est bien encore non par exemple
la cl hockey de l'alsace pour les
alsaciens disent il faut absolument que
l'alsace eux reconnus dans son identité
mais moi c'est un discours que je
comprends parfaitement
c'est d'ailleurs un très vieux sujet oui
le rappeur est question avec l'historien
jean-marie meyer appelée salle région
mémoire depuis le début du xviiie siècle
les intendants du roi se faisait
rappeler les principes qui devraient
régir l'alsace et c'est un vieux sujet
mais moi je considère qu'à pas
d'antinomie entre le respect de
l'identité alsacienne dont je comprends
qu'elles souhaitent s'exprimer qui est
une richesse pour nommer son
élargissement et son élargissement et je
vais vous dire pourquoi d'ailleurs un
portrait c'est au débat tout à l'heure
strasbourg comme capitale européenne
cessé d'être attaqué et au point qu' un
certain nombre de parlementaires
européens engagent toute une série des
mavs pour remettre en cause le statut de
strasbourg comme capitale européenne
et nous français nous dirions que
strasbourg doit être défendue comme
capitale européenne mais que nous
n'aurions pas suffisamment confiance en
elle pour en faire la capitale d'une
grande région ferait bien chercher là
qu'on verra de l'ump en tous les cas
certains évoquent un risque
constitutionnel en raison c'est vrai du
caractère hybride de la réforme puisque
et elle va faire se juxtaposer plusieurs
organisations pour un même territoire
pourrait même échelon et là il y aura
une métropole il ya là y aura encore un
département rural et ailleurs ce seront
des intercommunalités
non mais est ce que ce n'est pas étrange
d'abord et peut-être
anticonstitutionnelle je ne crois pas
cela parce que jamais le principe
d'unité d'indivisibilité de la
république n'a reposé sur l'idée qu' il
n'existe aucun droit aux territoires de
s'organiser en fonction de ce que sont
leurs spécificités leurs configurations
d'ailleurs en france toutes les
collectivités locales ne sont pas
organisés de la mer vous n'avez pas vous
n'avez pas les mêmes cercles
intercommunalités dans tous les
départements de france on notait la
grande métropole lyonnaise et puis des
départements
lien émiettement bus ou des structures
intercommunales on voit bien qu'il ya
des réalités des différences et le
conseil constitutionnel a toujours
veillé à ce que l'on articule diversité
est malade et de l'arrivée il faut
parler des départements parce que là
c'est encore flou on n'a pas très bien
compris le nombre de départements ruraux
qui vont subsister sachant que la
semaine dernière à votre place c'est
gérard collomb le sénateur maire de lyon
qui était là et qui avait trouvé un peu
théâtral finalement finalement c'est cet
accord qui a été obtenu à la suite d'un
chantage des radicaux de gauche il faut
le dire je crois pas qu'on puisse dire
ça comme ça parce que la première fois
que le premie s'est exprimé sur la
question de la suite qu'il donnerait à
l'avenir des départements il l'a fait à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avant
que cet accord n'intervienne bien avant
que cet accord n'intervienne parce que
précisément vous me posez la question
tout à l'heure de savoir si nous sommes
dans les coûts nous le sommes et c'est
parce que nous avons entendu un certain
nombre d'inquiétudes qui montaient des
territoires et notamment des territoires
ruraux qui craignent la relégation que
nous avons décidé sur les département
vient donc de prendre une possible il ya
une méthode qui a été définie et il y
aura trois situations la première
situation c'est celle où il ya des très
grandes métropoles dans les départements
qui peuvent fusionner avec les conseils
départementaux
c'est le cas de ce qui s'est passé à
lyon il y à t départements dans lesquels
il ya une intercommunalité qui est
suffisamment monte en puissance et qui
structurelles toi ô combien où les
départements tout cela va les
départementales les élections
départementales c'est au mois de mars
est régional sera en décembre de l'année
prochaine
et quand on interroge tous les élus
auraient volé fréquenté ils annoncent
tous une bérézina il soit catastrophe et
à l'avant ce qu'est ce que vous leur
dites pour qu'elles gardent confiance et
je le redis que les seuls combats
compères sont ceux qu'on mène pas et que
si la gauche s'employer à valoriser tout
ce qu'elle fait dans l'exercice du
gouvernement dans un contexte
extrêmement difficile pour des raisons
qui tiennent à la situation que nous
avons trouvés au climat économique
européen au climat politique globale
raymond moi j'avais votre âge vrai - on
a toujours une responsabilité en
politique il faut l'assumer mais je vais
prendre un exemple là ce que la semaine
dernière nous décidons de la diminution
des prélèvements sur les plus modestes
des français 2 1 milliards d'euros et
plus dans le même temps la gauche par là
la gauche sans se préoccuper de
valoriser ce qu'elle fait pour essayer
de faire en sorte y davantage de justice
il faut pas dès lors s'étonner qu'il
édifie cra bien moins quatre avions mené
campagne aux frondeurs à kivu après que
la première tranche je la fais allusion
au mieux à l'usma sera contre elle fait
allusion à tous ceux qui à gauche font
des phrases à destination de même plutôt
que d'avoir un terrain collant à
destination des français
alors il en sera question tout à l'heure
avec inferno mais tout de suite et
qu'athènes prigent de la sp qui va nous
rejoindre monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur a donc évoqué d'autres
dossiers importants dont vous avez la
charge
la menace terroriste bien sûr et
notamment par ailleurs qu'elle est qui
craque on le sait de partout au risque
d'exposer calais qui vous attend et où
se sont rendus le 5 milliard de chiffres
et sébastien borgeaud c'est un ballet
incessant au péril de leur vie des
migrants traversent chaque jour la
rocade pour rejoindre le port de calais
lorsqu'elle est embouteillée ils
prennent d'assaut les camions en groupe
pour se cacher à l'intérieur et tenter
leur chance vers l'angleterre
en attendant la barrière financé par les
anglais qui sera posée le long de la
route
cent policiers ont été envoyés en
renfort la semaine dernière par le
gouvernement
un effet d'annonce pour ce représentant
syndical la solution n'est pas pérenne
je pense que d'ici quelques semaines les
laissant fonctionnaires qui sont
arrivées vont partir sont des unités
mobiles
on a répondu on aura répondu à une
situation d'urgence
autre promesse du ministère de
l'intérieur le financement d'un lieu
d'accueil de jour la mairie a proposé de
mettre à disposition ce centre pour
organiser la distribution des repas et
des soins
seulement pour ne pas créer un nouveau
sangatte
le gouvernement ne prévoit pas
d'hébergement de nuit et surtout depuis
la dernière visite du ministre de
l'intérieur la mairie n'ait plus aucune
nouvelle du projet et j'ai dit au
ministre ce que je les ai vus début
octobre
j'ai monsieur le ministre
dans dix jours il gèle il neige
on se retrouve à -5 ou -10 vous faites
quoi
je n'ai pas de réponse car l'hiver
approche et cette année ce sont plus de
2000 migrants qui pourraient dormir
dehors avec les conflits libyen puis
syrien leur nombre a doublé dans calais
une situation qui exaspère les habitants
mais dans leur grande majorité ceux que
nous avons rencontrés se montre
solidaire des migrants c'est d'abord
grâce aux dons et aux bénévoles que
l'association salam distribue chaque
soir des repas à deux pas de la mairie
la colère hyper médiatisé ce n'est pas
contre les migrants qu'elle s'exprime
c'est un manque de courage politique un
manque de courage des gouvernants
successifs mais il ya des solutions au
niveau national on a prôné par exemple
de la mise en place de caen ne t'y pas
cher avec des temps jean militaire pour
les associations pas de solution
policière donc car les contrôles ne
dissuade pas les migrants comme khaled
qui s'est déjà fait prendre une
vingtaine de fois à bord d'un camion
même s'il ya beaucoup de policiers
j'essaierai d'aller là bas rien ne peut
m'arrêter
j'essayerai encore encore et encore il y
a trois jours l'un de ses amis a réussi
à passer en angleterre là bas dit il les
demandeurs d'asile sont nourris et logés
voilà bon savoir qu'apple présente pour
vous interroger notamment sur question
avez vous une réponse à apporter à la
maire de calais qui visiblement en
attend une j'ai reçu à deux reprises
la maire de calais je lui apporter une
réponse elle le sait elle fait un peu de
politique
c'est son droit et mais moi je suis en
charge de trouver des solutions qui
n'ont pas été trouvés depuis des années
d'ailleurs parce que ça fait des années
que ce problème est présente à quelle
est la raison ils sont gérés drame y est
d'ailleurs dans l'opposition qui est
attendu c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que le
ministre de l'intérieur je m'emploie les
mettre en oeuvre
quelles sont les solutions que j'ai
proposées natacha bouchart d'abord je
lui ai dit que je souhaitais que tout ce
qui relève de l'asile en france
le demande à calais plutôt que d'essayer
de passer dans des conditions
périlleuses en grande bretagne par
conséquent s est puisque je le lui dis
que j'ai renforcé les moyens de
l'administration en charge de l'asile
sur place pour convaincre les migrants
de demander l'asile en france et des
sortir des griffes des acteurs de
l'immigration irrégulière premièrement
deuxièmement je lui ai indiqué que
j'allais poursuivre les retours à la
frontière pour ce qui relève de
l'immigration irrégulière parce que on
ne peut pas faire autrement
troisièmement je lui ai indiqué que j'ai
été bluffé d'accord pour qu'on mette en
place un accueil de jour pour faire en
sorte que les migrants ne soient pas
confrontés à la faim au froid des
problèmes sanitaires
ce qui jusqu'à présent n'avaient pas été
faits notamment par les gouvernements
que soutenait madame bouchard et qui
survolait calais qu'ils appelaient la
jungle en hélicoptère c'est parce que
des banques sur ce sur cet accueil
oui voilà date c'est très bien qu'elle a
un accord elle sait très bien que j'ai
donné mon accord sur ce site
elle sait très bien qui est des réunions
interministérielles qui sont tenues
cette semaine à l'occasion desquelles
nous allons débloquer des financements
et elle sait parfaitement que je me
déplacerai calé dans les prochains jours
oui dans les prochains jours dans le
courant du mois de novembre
je n'ai pas souhaité aller à calais pour
faire du spectacle verdun déclare marie
le pen lourde si encore une fois qu'ils
ont survolé calé en hélicoptère faisant
des camps déclaration en disant qu'ils
avaient tous réglés sans avoir apporté
aucune solution
j'irai à calais pour mettre en oeuvre
concrètement les dispositifs sur lequel
je me suis mobilisé pour lesquelles
l'état a décidé de mettre en oeuvre des
financements d'abord pour rencontrer les
forces de police les 100 policiers
supplémentaires que j'ai à louer à
calais pour faire face à la situation
resteront à quai les aussi longtemps que
la situation sera celle ci contrairement
à ce que je viens d'entendre
deuxièmement j'irai aussi pour constater
le dispositif de sécurisation du port
pour lequel j'ai négocié avec les
britanniques au cours des dernières
semaines
un dispositif de financement qui les
engage c'était quand même plus malin que
donné que de dénoncer les accords du
touquet sans contrepartie troisièmement
j'irai aussi pour indiquer quels sont
les moyens que l'état mobilise
pour assurer le fonctionnement de cet
accueil de jour j'irai aussi pour
expliquer les moyens que nous mobilisons
je rencontrerai les acteurs de l'eau
fera pour de faire en sorte que les
migrants demande d'asile à calais il
faudra je ne suis pas pardonnez moi je
termine sur ce poids moi je ne suis pas
un ministre de l'intérieur qui fait des
phrases tous les jours sans apporter de
solutions il y en a eu
il s'étonne d'ailleurs que je fasse
moins de phrases que les mois ce que
j'essaie de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
des solutions
il travaille et j ai travaillé au plan
européen à travers la tournée de cet été
qui aboutit à des décisions du conseil
européen qui reprennent très exactement
les propositions que l'avait fait
pendant l'été qui avait été validé par
toutes les capitales européennes on
pourra en parler je les fais en
mobilisant les britanniques à travers ce
plan de 15 millions d'euros pour qu'il y
ait des solutions humanitaires et de
sécurité du port à calais et je les fais
en prenant mes responsabilités comme
nice à l'intérieur pour qu'il y ait une
solution aussi française à cannes est là
pourquoi ne faire qu'un accueil de jour
pourquoi pas un accueil jour et nuit
parce que l'accueil de nuit et un
accueil qui relève du plan grand froid
qui mobilise d'autres ministères que le
mien et sur ce sujet aussi l'état
prendra ses responsabilités je vais
passer ces migrants comme des comme des
réfugiés donc mais comme des clandestins
mais pas du tout puisque je viens de
vous dire que ces migrants qui relève de
l'asie l'enfant souhaité qu'on leur
propose asile et que leur proposerait de
deux migrants susceptibles de demander
l'asile en france sur l'âge mentionné
1400 à 1500 euros constitue à calais une
majorité mais pour l'instant sur cette
cette démarche n'est cuit obtenir un
accord que 200 migrants
parce que ces migrants sont entre les
mains des passeurs c'est à dire des
acteurs des filières de l'immigration
irrégulière
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour dire madame
le pen qui est allé faire tout un sketch
chaque année sur le thème le
gouvernement est mou et ne réagit pas
contre les filières de l'immigration
irrégulière que le nombre de filières de
l'immigration irrégulière que nous avons
démantelé en 2014 et 30% supérieur à ce
qui avait été fait en 2013 et en 2013
céder 30% supérieur ce qui avait été
fait en 2010 et plus de 200 filières de
l'immigration irrégulière
en 2014 six de démantèlement de deux
directs de deux filières pardon n'est
pas aussi proportionnelle à
l'augmentation de migrants non mais il
il faut le savoir il faut que tout le
monde le comprenne des filières
organisées du crime
au plan mondial qui sont de véritables
acteurs de la traite des êtres humains
qui précise qu'ils se changent de
schengen pas soi mais pas du tout ce qui
s'est passé là aussi je vais répondre ce
qui s'est passé depuis des mois c'est
quoi ce sont des acteurs de l'imitation
servile qui sont encore une fois
véritables criminels qui face à des
hommes et des femmes désespérées en
afrique du nord
laurent dit prenez des embarcations de
fortune en prélevant sur ces personnes
un véritable impôt sur la mort les ont
mis de plus en plus nombreux sur des
embarcations de plus en plus frêle sous
prétexte qu'il y avait une opération
italienne qui s'appelait maha nostrum
qui est une opération de sauvetage en
mer moyennant quoi cette opération a
sauvé plus de vies mais à la fin il y
avait plus de morts et ses acteurs de
l'immigration irrégulière ils sont en
afrique du nord en lien avec d'autres
filières du crime organisé
ils sont en italie en europe et parfois
dans nos gars et ils sont aussi à calais
ils sont aussi en grande bretagne et je
suis résolu à démanteler ces filières et
comment est ce qu'on le fait les
demandes et aux britanniques d'agir en
liaison avec nos polices et nos services
à londres comme à calais et nous
agissons ensemble pour que ces filières
soient démantelées aussi sur le pays de
destination
nous agissons avec les pays de la bande
sahélo saharienne pour démanteler ces
filières
je me suis rendu en mauritanie il ya de
cela peu de temps pour arrêter avec les
pays de l'afrique du nord des
dispositifs de coopération qui
permettent ce démantèlement et nous le
faisons dans nos gares dans nos
aéroports gérés par exemple récemment
fait une visite à la gare du nord pour
constater avec que les effectifs de la
police nationale
l'importance du travail de démantèlement
d immigration irrégulière a été
effectuée dans corse que le pen dit à
laxisme gouvernemental sur les filières
de l'immigration irrégulière c'est un
bol d'or est ce que justement sur cette
migration plus globale en europe et il
faudrait revoir schengen sans parler
forcément il a aussi sur la question de
schengen le problème n'est pas de savoir
si notre appartenance à cet espace
prenons le sujet sérieusement raid de
seconde la question de schengen n'est
pas tant le texte du code schengen
lui-même que les conditions de son
application
si on supprime d'abord l'idée que les
migrants viennent parce qu'il ya ces
encaissements supprimer des comédiens
formés je ne l'expliqué d'abord cette
idée que les migrants viennent tant
nombreux en europe parce qu'il ya
schengen est tout simplement stupide il
n'y a pas un migrant qui a lu le code
schengen qui tombe amoureux du code
schengen et qui s'est déjà bien en
europe parce que schengen non ils
viennent en europe comme partout
ailleurs dans le monde
parce qu'ils sont persécutés à chaque
fois que vous avez des états qui torture
qui exécutent qui décapite qui ou des
groupes terroristes vous avez des
personnes qui prennent le chemin de
l'exode parce qu'elles sont persécutés
c'est vieux comme l'histoire de
l'humanité et ce n'est pas parce que
vous décidez à un moment donné de faire
des contrôles partout aux frontières que
vous allez empêcher ces mouvements de
population et par ailleurs la france est
une terre d'asile pour tous ceux qui
sont persécutés et je n'ai pas entendu
d'ailleurs que quiconque proposé de
remettre cela en cause
en revanche schengen est mal appliquée
je vais prendre un exemple très concret
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est
appliquer les règles de schengen en
italie à l'arrivée des migrants en
italie c'est à dire prendre des
empreintes digitales les inscrire dans
la bande
la banque eurodac pour permettre les
processus d'émission et avoir une
politique européenne de l'asile donc la
question c'est pas de faire schengen 2
comme certains le proposent ou de
remettre en cause schengen c'est de
faire en sorte que les règles de
schengen soit appliquée et que lorsqu'il
y à des améliorations apportées elles
soient modifiées je prends un autre
exemple dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
je serai là c'est vraiment à ce que on
modifie un certain nombre de
dispositions du code schengen pour
pouvoir faire sur un certain nombre de
vols en provenance de pays peuvent poser
problème
des contrôles plus systématiques y
compris le nos ressortissants mais ça on
peut le faire par une modification du
code schengen
et schengen face au terrorisme c'est un
plus considérable parce que si demain je
n'ai plus schengen je n'ai plus système
d'information schengen
je ne sais plus je n'ai plus aucune
information des pays dans lesquels
transitent les terroristes
il n'y a plus de banques jeunes aussi
décrié et d'un allié dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme king n est une
solution je vais vous dire pourquoi je
vais prendre des exemples très concrets
lorsque vous avez un terroriste qui est
parti de france et qui a parti de france
en partant à partir d'un autre aéroport
parce qu'ils avaient peur d'être
contrôlé en france le système
d'information schengen me permet
immédiatement y compris l'inscription au
fichier des personnes recherchées de mal
penher européen de savoir que ce sachet
personne j'ai sorti des balances qui
avaient reculé de france pour aller
faire le djihad vous aviez dit n'y en
avait neuf cent trente le premier
ministre a parlé de plus de 1000 est ce
que vous avez de nouveaux chiffres non
le chiffre le plus récent c'est
effectivement plus de 1000 le nombre de
ceux qui sont concernés par ces
activités terroristes a augmenté de 82%
depuis le début de l'année 2014 est un
phénomène que connaissent la plupart des
pays de l'union européenne pour des
raisons qui tiennent à d'efficaces will
bien entendu diversité bien entendu et
donc la volonté qui est la nôtre c'est
de faire en sorte que l'on puisse
stopper ces départs parce que ceux qui
partent prêt quand et décapitations les
exécutions en nombre et reviennent animé
par le seul instinct de la violence et
donc ça il faut y mettre fin
justement dernière question capteur est
ce qu'il revienne justement parler de ce
qu'il revienne refaire un djihad en
français ce qui est cette probabilité
est ce qu'il ya un niveau du danger qui
poussent mais un certain nombre parce
que quand ils sont encore une fois
rencontré la violence et rien d'autre et
qu'il revienne
animé par le seul instinct de la
violence et de la haine effectivement il
peut comme elles peuvent commettre ces
actes et encore une fois si nous prenons
sont priés de 100% de précaution sur ce
sujet comme sur d'autres dont on parlait
au début de l'émission
il peut y avoir à un moment donné malgré
tout des risques qui sera juste des mots
il faut vraiment évident puisque vous
évaluer comment est ce que vous
qualifiez le danger terroriste
aujourd'hui en france je le qualifie de
sérieux et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous sommes dans une vigilance maximale
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
voulu que nous adoptions des
dispositions législatives qui permettent
la progression des français dans le
respect rojo des libéraux suc assez
général droite gauche centre notamment
au sénat et à l'assemblée nationale
merci beaucoup et casas dans perrine
tarneaud arrive maintenant pour évoquer
le climat politique avec bien sûr le
bras de fer sur la ligne que doit suivre
le gouvernement
sandra cerqueira manuel valls est passé
à l'offensive imposant sa politique
clairement social-libéral allant jusqu'à
vouloir changer le nom du parti
socialiste se disant même prêt à
s'ouvrir au centre autant de provocation
pour l'ailé gauche du parti
les idées de manuel valls elle qui les a
exprimés récemment sont très
minoritaires et à elles sont très
passéiste en plus de ça vire cette
espèce de cocktails idéologie qui serait
une pincée de ghajar schröder une pincée
de tony blair est un gros socle de
clemenceau ma paraît extrêmement daté et
si le premier ministre considère qu'être
de gauche aujourd'hui ses produits un
obstacle
qui mentir lui les conséquences le rang
des frondeurs ne cesse de grossir
il ya désormais des anciens ministres
qui s'abstiennent sur le budget c'est
inédit le carvounas invite les opposants
à rentrer dans le rang
il faut que chacun soit en
responsabilité dans le sens que nous
sommes au pouvoir
les français ne comprennent pas ce que
nous faisons quand il sait s'abstiennent
dans le vote
ils nous disent vous n'êtes pas en
capacité de gouverner ensemble qu'on
vous pouvez gérer nos problèmes il faut
vraiment qu'on revienne à raison qu'on
retrouve cette dynamique est elle un
autre moment de chant 2012
une énième crise c'est du pain béni pour
l'ump qui se gausse des difficultés de
la majorité
il ya une majorité de circonstance de
gens qui ont peur d'être dissous et
d'être écrabouillé aux élections et donc
le gouvernement ne tient plus que comme
ça mais à plus de majorité d'idées
résultat des courses c'est que on a tous
le sentiment dan désordre institutionnel
extrêmement grave
seule solution possible pour
l'opposition la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale
mais ce serait une menace de plus pour
le gouvernement déjà mal en point
on est dans un flou on ne sait pas qui
gouvernait une sorte de vacance du
pouvoir qui est très anxiogène parce
qu'on est en période de crise on a un
président qui n'assument pas d'être
président et après les ministres qui
n'assume plus tout à fait d'être premier
ministre qui veut être un petit peu au
dessus donc en fait chacun on est au
même niveau fait un match de boxe quand
les deux boxeurs sont sur le ring
maintenant ils sont au même niveau ils
vont se taper dessus et on commence
juste à voir le début de sa de
l'affrontement les ambitieux aiment
avoir un train d' avance chez les
socialistes on est déjà dans l'après
hollande
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
avoir fait une croix sur la candidature
du président en 2017
voilà alors sans doute pas vos bacs à
mes questions de perrine tarneaud sur la
division d'abord au sein du parti
socialiste dernier vote en date c'était
mardi à l'assemblée nationale 1 34
députés socialistes qui se sont abstenus
sur le budget de la sécurité sociale
alors certes cinq de moins que la
dernière fois mais dans ces
abstentionnistes on retrouve benoît
hamon aurélie filippetti vos anciens
collègues du gouvernement que leur
répondez vous
mais moi je suis avant tout soucieux de
valoriser ce que nous faisons et je
pense qu'il est préférable de regarder
les actes plutôt que de se camper
systématiquement dans des postures
qu'est ce que nous avons fait depuis que
nous sommes gouvernement et je le dis
notamment à mes anciens collègues qui
prétendent ou en tous les cas souhaite
le camper à la gauche du parti
socialiste
nous avons décidé de remettre
l'éducation nationale qui avait été
considérablement affaiblie en situation
de former dans de bonnes conditions
les jeunes générations nous avons très
60000 postes d'ailleurs benoît hamon le
sait très bien qui s'était réjoui de ces
décisions lorsqu'il était encore six
semaines mission de l'éducation
nationale avait préparé une remarquable
rentrée scolaire nous avons décidé de
mettre en place un plan pauvreté de 2,5
milliards d'euros pour les plus pauvres
de nos concitoyens nous avons décidé là
où il y avait une justice et une
politique de sécurité à la peine de
recréer des postes et non seulement des
postes mais de donner des moyens à la
justice et à la police et à la
gendarmerie pour qu'elle puisse
accomplir leurs missions régaliennes
dans de bonnes conditions
oui mais je me permets de le leur
rappeler parce que c'est ça la politique
que nous conduisons et plus toujours
dans quoi dans une stratégie de celui-ci
vous leur poserait la question moi si
vous me demandez de leur répondre
donc je le fais bien volontiers et je
leur réponds en leur disant voilà ce que
nous faisons et pour ce qui concerne mon
département ministériel et mon
prédécesseur s'était mobilisée pour cela
et j'ai repris ces sujets en les mettant
sur les métiers pour qu'ils se
transcrire en texte de loi on met en
place une politique de l'asile qui doit
permettre de réduire le temps de
traitement des dossiers des demandeurs
d'asile de 24 à 9 mois ont créé des
postes au sein de l'ofpra pour que le
traitement des demandeurs d'asile soit
digne de ce nom on reconnaît davantage
leurs droits ou s'exclament elles ont
trait plusieurs milliers de postes de
places supplémentaires en centres
d'accueil pour demandeurs d'asile
mais tout ça je le dis à toute la gauche
non plutôt que de passer sont quant à
eux le bilan ce n'est pas que ça oui
mais enfin le bilan on sait qu'on est
sur le chômage parle de françois
rebsamen mais il ya une situation de
croissants et sort des 1 vous me posez
la question de savoir si nous sommes un
gouvernement
de gauche ou pas et si nous avons des
raisons d'être fiers de ce que nous
faisons ou pas je vous réponds je vous
réponds voilà ce que nous faisons et
vous me demandez ministre je veillerai à
ce que des banques et du positionne été
2011 des bouchons démissionnaire donc je
leur dis sincèrement voilà ce que nous
faisons et voilà ce que nous avons fait
ensemble
aussi lorsque vous étiez gouvernement
visiblement fiers de ce que vous faisiez
bon donc je réponds cela ensuite il ya
un deuxième paquet question qui concerne
la politique économique et sociale et
sur la politique économique et sociale
vous avez effectivement une situation
dans laquelle il ya du chômage du
chômage qui est un véritable concert
pour la société française avec l'accusé
a quand même du ministre chargé du
travail la lutte contre le chômage dans
une europe qui ne connaît pas de
croissance et vous avez vu que même
l'allemagne que l'on a l'habitude de
présenter comme le très bon élève de
l'économie européenne est aujourd'hui
dans une situation de croissance zéro
annoncé finalement un exemple mais donc
nous menons pas de reprise nous menons
un combat au sein de l'union européenne
pour faire en sorte que la politique de
l'union européenne soient réorientés et
plus la france sera forte en europe
c'est-à-dire plus elle aura fait son
devoir de rétablissement de ses combats
large public et fait les réformes d'une
part et d'autre part plus le président
de la république sera fort d'une
majorité qui veut avec lui la
réorientation de l'union européenne plus
nous serons en situation d'accélérer le
calendrier de cette orientation
donc tous ceux qui tapent du poing sur
la table et je ne suis d'ailleurs pas
loin de les soutenir pour dire l'europe
d'autant printemps un autre chemin et
qui souhaitent que le président de la
république réussi cette réorientation
seraient bien inspirés de l'aider à la
réussir comment approuver soutenir quand
même certains défendeurs en tapant du
poing sur la table
je ne dis pas que je soutiens savais pas
ce que je viens de dire je viens de dire
pourquoi le présent dans le public quand
il demande la réorientation de l'europe
pour davantage de croissance
n'est-il pas socialiste lorsque nous
souhaitons que l'union européenne
s'engage vers une grande politique
d'investissements publics qui permettent
à l'économie européenne de se donner des
moyens de se doter des atouts de sa
compétitivité n'étant pas déterminée
et l'eau et lorsque un certain nombre de
socialistes demandent à ce que cela
aille plus vite
ce que l'on peut comprendre je leur dis
simplement qu'ils seraient mieux
inspirés s'ils veulent que les choses
aillent plus vite de soutenir davantage
le président l'amérique dans son chalet
puisque vous avez été ministre du budget
on peut saluer peut-être aujourd'hui la
performance de bercy puisque sans
économies nouvelles le gouvernement
vient de décrocher l'approbation de la
commission européenne
paris n'a pas revoir sa copie est ce
qu'il ya un magicien merci médias pas de
magicien bercy a bercy il ya une rigueur
et une exigence et je serai bien
peut-être voilà non ce ne serait pas
bien parce que ce n'est pas avec de la
magie qu'on résout les problèmes d'un
pays c'est avec de la détermination de
la rigueur de la vérité nous avons
engagé une politique d'économies
budgétaires
cette politique d'économies budgétaires
nous l'avons engagé parce que c'est la
condition du rétablissement de nos
comptes
je veux redonner trois chiffres qui
montrent l'effort qui a été accompli et
qui sont trois chiffres que le présente
à l'opposition lorsque nous sommes
arrivés en situation de responsabilité
l'augmentation des dépenses publiques
était de 1,7 pour cent en période 2007
monsieur sarkozy qui prétend revenir
pour régler tous les problèmes de la
france et notamment la question de ses
déficits les dépenses publiques à
augmenter la dépense publique de 170
milliards d'euros lorsqu'il était
présente dans le public c'est ça la
réalité
le budget que les présenter en 2014
c'était 09 s'il ya une division par deux
du rythme d'augmentation de la dépense
publique et cette année on est à 0 2
donc l'europe voit bien qu'il y à un
effort de maîtrise à l'appui de dépenses
publiques elle voit l'exécution de nos
budgets et elle voit par conséquent que
nous exécutons nos objectifs et que si
les déficits ne diminue pas ce n'est pas
parce que nous maîtrisons pas la
dépenser parce qu'il n'y a pas de
croissance et l'europe commencent à se
rendre compte aussi que le fait qu'il
n'y ait pas de croissance pose des
problèmes à certains nombre de pays de
l'union européenne et l'europe c'est ça
à condition d'être fort dans l'europe
mais non c'est être déterminée dans
incapable de faire entendre sa voix dans
ce contexte ce qui reste des marges de
manoeuvre pour françois hollande pour
rebondir mais de le réformer
mais la marge de manoeuvre puisque
bruxelles continuer à nous réclamer des
réformes de structure mais d'abord les
réformes de structure nous les faisons
pour nous mêmes nous ne les faisons pas
parce que bruxelles ne les réclame nous
les faisons parce que nous sommes la
france
que nous avons un rôle particulier à
jouer au sein de l'union européenne que
l'union européenne ne peut pas avancer
s'il n'y a pas un moteur franco-allemand
qui fonctionne ça ne veut pas dire
d'ailleurs que notre attachement au
moteur franco-allemand la volonté que
nous avons de redresser nos comptes doit
nous conduire à capituler face à une
europe qui ne va pas assez vite et assez
loin sur les politiques de croissance
sur les politiques d'investissement donc
nous menons tous ses combats à la fois
et ses combats il faut les mener avec
détermination mais aussi avec
crédibilité que les lésés cherchent des
idées et que j'en perds juillet rien
dresse à tous les ministres un appel à
projets qu'est ce que vous lui avez
proposé mais nous cherchons des idées en
permanence parce que ce n'est pas parce
que nous gérons un pays avec la volonté
de bien le gérer qu'il est tout d'un
coup interdit de réfléchir d'imaginer et
de proposer
donc moi je lui ai proposé d'engager le
pays dans une grande réforme de
l'administration territoriale de l'état
en avons besoin pour la proximité et
nous en avons besoin pour l'efficacité
de l'état deux dernières questions pour
finir 2010 est michel rocard qui
déconseille à françois hollande de se
représenter
est-ce qu'ils parlent d'évidence michel
rocard au vu de la cote de popularité de
l'incision qui appartient au président
de la république
moi je vois un président de la
république qui est tous les jours sur le
métier qu'il ya un profond de conscience
de ce qu'est la situation du pays mais
qui aime profondément son pays et les
français et qui prend des risques et ne
manque pas de courage et la vérité un
jour
puis toujours par apparaître et françois
mitterrand m'avait dit dans les années
quatre-vingt quatorze ans que je me suis
engagé en politique
sachez une chose c'est qu'en politique
on apparaît à la fin toujours pour ce
qu'on a
même quand il ya des bourrasques même
quand on prend des paquets de mer à la
fin quand on prend des sommets bien sûr
et à la fin les choses finissent en mai
rappelle pour ce qu'elles sont françois
bayrou qui juge la dissolution
inévitable que lui répondez vous je
reprends face aubert ou que j'aime bien
et lequel
lesquels vous auriez aimé travailler
c'est un homme de qualité
moi je n'ai pas su pas dans l'intérêt de
la place dans la maison des
progressistes des voûtes ni par manuel
va je vous ai dit que c'est un homme de
qualité ne vous ai pas dit autre chose
dont je vous laisse libre de vos
exportations et je réponds à la françois
bayrou et vous allez voir que la qualité
que je lui reconnais pas que ça sert de
nécessairement d'accord avec lui qu'il a
tort de spéculer
parce que la démocratie c'est pas une
spéculation permanente et une majorité
cette majorité elle a été élue
démocratiquement comme le président de
la république l'a été et ce ne sont pas
les sondages qui peuvent se superposer
ou se substituer aux élections en
permanence parce que sinon il ya une
élection par jour puisqu'il ya au moins
un sondage par jour
un corps donc voilà le chef de l'état
reste le maître des horloges dernières
questions traitant est seul maître des
horloges qu'il ya des principes
démocratiques et républicains
et quand on est élu pour la durée d'un
mandat il peut toujours y avoir des gens
qui spéculent sur la démocratie en
proposant des dissolutions et des
élections tous les jours je pense que
c'est pas une bonne manière de rendre
service à la démocratie et la république
merci était avec nous perrine bonsoir à
tous et la semaine prochaine notre
invité sera gérard larcher le président
du sénat
bonsoir à tous et à très vite